we film protest and protesters
interactions with police officers
live streamers are extra safety for
other demonstrators and to also expose
like some of the tactics illegal and
legal that the police are using and so
they try to snatch up live streamers
some of the backlash that I received
included a police officer contacting my
job they found out who I was I've been
arrested twice during live streaming
they call me a protest later I'm far
from a protest leader I'm I'm behind the
scenes i'm just a supporter I've been
threatened online from st. Louis cop
talk please post the identity of all
these troublemakers they all want to
hide behind pseudonyms out them
addresses phone numbers license numbers
everything you can find my placement
plan was just posted on Twitter this
morning so I don't know how long my jobs
in the last now